Seniorentreff кіно але rap.de
погрожував їй розбудити тиск хотів би
почати тут же знову з
питання важкого від бомбардувань
які там відбуваються, нелюдські
вони для населення
жорстокий досвід і я особисто
не думаю, що це також спрацює
терористів від мирних людей до
розділяйтеся, коли у вас такі напади
постійно їздить і це теж
політичний процес не виникає таким чином
може
але є російська
відповідальність чітка відповідальність
з позицією росії там в
Сирія також впливає на Асада
фізичні вправи та життя чоловіків, що
життя людей, а також майбутнє
політичного процесу
зберегти і на тому, що ми маємо в усьому
вказав для ясності